[Music]
on this wednesday night inflation
aggravation
the skyrocketing rate not seen in nearly
four decades everything's more expensive
these days for everybody the
consequences for consumers bruised
businesses
and concerns cropping up at some
canadian farms it's out of our control
how a perfect storm of extreme weather
events could put further strain on the
food supply chain we'll hear from the
experts on ways to curtail the rising
costs and when those prices might peak
we are starting to see
the light and the sky is falling a new
warning about the risks posed by
humanity's space junk
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff semple
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us the cost of living just keeps
climbing from gas to groceries prices
are rising at a rate not seen in decades
canada's inflation rate rose to 8.1
percent last month that's the fastest
annual increase in nearly 40 years
statistics canada says the price
acceleration in june was largely driven
by soaring prices at the pumps they're
up more than 50 percent compared to last
year now canada is not the only country
dealing with rising costs right now u.s
inflation just jumped to 9.1 percent and
in the united kingdom inflation hit 9.4
percent that's the highest level since
way back in 1982.
in our top story tonight ann gaviola
reports on the consequences for
consumers and when those prices might
peak
sticker shock at the pumps affects the
price of most everything you can buy
because it's moved by truck train and
ship it's been a pretty pretty scary
time so we're we're hit with a very high
food cost
very high utility cost
very high labor cost food across the
board costs nearly nine percent more
hitting restaurants that serve a lot of
meat really hard the wholesale costs of
beef have doubled uh give or take over
the last year and
we actually had to increase our prices
and customers dealing with rising costs
are cutting back on dining out
the conference board of canada's latest
note says canadians are looking for
something to blame for inflation but
there are multiple causes and no smoking
gun as inflation becomes politicized
it's worth remembering that global and
domestic tangible and intangible factors
are contributing
blame has been directed at the bank of
canada for not acting sooner to combat
inflation instead it's unleashed jumbo
rate hikes since march to cool the
economy and hopefully tame the rising
cost of living this matters because it
gives people predictability to plan
their spending and saving decisions to
budget
and to live their lives without having
to worry about what prices are going to
be next week next month or next year but
higher rates in canada don't combat high
global oil or food prices both boosted
by war in ukraine and supply chain
snarls economist too yen says some
relief may come in the fall we might be
reaching peak inflation by the end of
the summer but it's hard to say 100
for now the unpredictability is rattling
households and businesses alike i've
actually just come away from a meeting
with my major supplier
to talk about not so much the price of
things today but what can we expect
coming down the pipe and fears of a
recession are mounting though many say a
short economic slowdown may be better
than years of high inflation ann gaviola
global news toronto
while many canadian families are
struggling with those growing grocery
bills farmers are warning that extreme
weather and challenging growing
conditions risk pushing food prices even
higher morgan campbell has that story
it's a challenge at this time these are
the bean and corn crops at sarah woods's
family farm in mitchell ontario judging
by the way they look it is clear they
could use a drink but that rainfall has
been hard to come by this year as much
of the region is dealing with an
abnormally dry season it is building a
root system that's sucking up as much
moisture as it can but if it doesn't
have some extra water then all that
moisture is just going to a crop that
can't actually produce anything there is
concern that less rain in parts of
alberta ontario quebec and newfoundland
could amount to lower yields it depends
really very much on the significance of
the of the drought in your particular
location but also what you're growing in
lethbridge county where crops were
already dry they now must contend with
more damage after a 140 kilometer an
hour windstorm that swept through parts
of southeastern alberta resulting in
more damage to fields of sugar beet
plants corn and canola it was a
20-minute storm but it's got 12 months
of consequences for it
the country's food supply chain is
already strained due to last year's
drought in russia's invasion of ukraine
the impacts cut both ways for canadians
we are poised to put more grain into the
global system than last year which could
benefit farmers but we will all feel the
effects on our grocery bills too every
single commodity will have a different
cycle and will impact food prices very
differently but there is hope crops
could bounce back if drier parts of
canada see rainfall in august even
though farmers invest greatly on seed
and fertilizer to give their crops the
best chance they are almost always at
the mercy of mother nature when we don't
have water it's not
it's out of our control in uncertain
times canadian farmers know the
importance of staying grounded morgan
campbell global news toronto
and coming up a little later we'll hear
more from food policy professor sylvain
charlebois about exactly which products
are seeing the worst sticker shock and
when those price pressures might finally
ease
british officials are tallying up the
damage one day after a flurry of fires
sparked by those record-breaking
temperatures tore through parts of
london
at least 41 properties have been
destroyed in london 14 in norfolk five
in lincolnshire and smaller numbers
elsewhere
the british capital was one of 15 areas
in the uk that declared a major incident
yesterday as the country recorded its
hottest day in history topping 40
degrees celsius
temperatures have now slightly cooled
but as ross lord reports the heat wave
is still fueling devastating fires
across europe
in the united kingdom finally some
relief with the arrival of cooler
temperatures and higher humidity but the
scorching heat wave and the rampant
wildfires have left a mark that won't
soon be erased reminding families who've
lost their homes what matters most i
just keep thinking about
how worse it could have been you know i
mean we've lost everything but we've all
still got our lives i think everyone got
out safely summer wildfires are not new
in europe but these blazes happened
earlier in the season and they've been
more devastating than usual in spain and
portugal firefighters have extinguished
roughly half of the wildfires but the
heat has contributed to more than one
thousand deaths spanish prime minister
pedro sanchez says the wildfires are
more evidence that climate change kills
in parts of greece flames are persistent
and residents are exhausted
we saved our home at the last minute
says this man but the fire keeps
reigniting and the fire engine has run
out of water
back in the uk london's fire service is
responding to seven times as many calls
as usual busier than it's been since
world war ii
beating the heat has also turned tragic
at least 13 people have died while
swimming many of them teenage boys the
government has been at the forefront of
the international efforts to reach net
zero but the impacts of climate change
are with us now but despite readily
adopting phrases like climate change
emergency political leaders are still
not following through according to
researchers and activists we saw that
with our response to covid19 our
governments were talking to us every day
telling us about what they were doing
what organizations were doing and how
people could contribute we still haven't
seen a response like that to the climate
crisis for parts of europe there is some
rain in the forecast but hot weather is
expected to continue in southern and
eastern parts of the continent ross lord
global news
heat warnings remain in effect for
millions of americans as a sprawling
heat dome is now baking states from
coast to coast with more temperature
records expected to be broken this week
the u.s president is feeling the heat
facing calls to declare a climate change
emergency jackson proskow reports on joe
biden's new plan
100 million americans nearly one in
three are under some kind of heat
warning including the entire state of
oklahoma and most of texas where 94
percent of the state is experiencing
severe drought this is not your parents
or grandparents whether this is new
weather that we're experiencing because
of climate change with the climate alarm
sounding president joe biden traveled to
a former coal-fired power plant to
announce executive action supporting
offshore wind farms and aid to harden
american cities against extreme heat and
weather it is literally not figuratively
a clear and present danger
the health of our citizens and our
communities is literally at stake
biden stopped short of declaring a
national climate emergency environmental
groups believe he should be using more
of his executive powers to meet the
urgency of the moment we want to see
things like you know an end to new
leasing of fossil for fossil fuels on
public lands and public waters
and real efforts to crack down on
emissions because
you know the problem can't wait that's
because the u.s is on course to miss its
greenhouse gas targets there was a
pledge to reduce emissions to 50 percent
below 2005 levels by the end of the
decade but at current rates that
reduction will only be a quarter to a
third of 2005 levels well off course
the president's modest actions are
expected to have only a modest impact in
meeting those goals biden's once
ambitious climate agenda remains blocked
by lawmakers in congress and the
realities of high gas prices and the war
in ukraine you know unfortunately we are
a laggard when it comes to climate
action it's really been
inconsistent
time is running out to avoid the worst
impacts of the climate crisis and there
are warnings the longer real action
takes the more drastic it will have to
be
jackson prosko global news washington
hockey canada is launching an
independent review following allegations
the organization kept a fund to pay off
sexual abuse victims hockey canada says
the move takes effect immediately and
the national equity fund will be
exclusively dedicated towards safety
wellness and equity initiatives the
organization has been under fire after
settling a lawsuit with a woman who
accused members of the 2018 world junior
hockey team of sexual assault well
tonight police in london ontario where
the alleged assault took place announced
their own internal review to see if
anything was missed in their criminal
investigation
military police say they've laid charges
against the former head of personnel at
the canadian armed forces in connection
with an inappropriate relationship with
a subordinate lieutenant general stephen
whalen faces two charges that are
specific to the military and cannot be
tried in a civilian court whalen stepped
aside from his role as head of personnel
last october after allegations of sexual
misconduct the department of national
defense says an investigation did not
reveal enough evidence to support
criminal charges
boris says goodbye
coming up the message the outgoing
british pm is sending to his successors
welcome back the european union is
telling member states to cut gas usage
by 15 percent after vladimir putin
warned the flow of russian gas could be
curbed significantly
overall the flow of russian gas is now
less than one-third
to what it used to be for example at the
same time last year
russia is blackmailing us
russia is using energy as a weapon
the warning comes as the main pipeline
between russia and western europe is set
to restart tomorrow after a maintenance
shutdown but european leaders are
worried the russian president will
reduce the flow of energy to retaliate
for western sanctions and support from
ukraine
for his part putin is blaming canada for
any potential reductions in the gas
supply the russian leader cited delays
and quality concerns over the repair
work done on a turbine in montreal the
canadian government has been under fire
for exempting that turbine from
sanctions and allowing the equipment to
be returned to russia
well after being kicked out of number 10
downing street by his own party boris
johnson addressed the british parliament
for the last time as prime minister in a
speech that was very much on brand
number one stay close to the americans
stick up for the ukrainians stick up for
freedom and democracy everywhere i want
to thank everybody here and
hasta la vista baby thank you
the race to succeed johnson as tory
leader and prime minister has now come
down to just two candidates former
finance minister rishi sunak and foreign
secretary liz truss the result of the
final vote will be announced on
september the 5th
italy's government appears to be
crumbling italian prime minister mario
draghi won a confidence motion today but
it was widely considered a hollow
victory after three of his key coalition
allies boycotted the vote draghi's plan
for a coalition government now seems
likely to fail meaning that country
could be heading for a fall election
in sri lanka protesters are vowing to
fight on after the country's prime
minister was voted in as the next
president the sri lankan parliament
chose ranil rikramasinghe to lead the
country one week after his predecessor
fled amid protests over runaway
inflation shortages of food fuel and
medicine protesters are calling for a
new election within the year and
constitutional changes to limit the
president's power
food for thought ahead we speak with an
expert about inflation's impact on
groceries and how you can cut costs
canadians could soon be facing even more
travel turbulence westjet workers in
calgary and vancouver have voted 98
in favor of a strike more than 700
employees could walk off the job as
early as next week if they can't reach a
deal with the airline unifor says wages
are a key issue in contract talks this
comes as westjet confirms winter
services to charlottetown fredericton
sydney and quebec city will be suspended
in november as the airline focuses on
service in western canada and to sun
destinations
from flying to driving to eating life is
suddenly a lot more expensive and for
more on how long these record high
prices are expected to last and what
canadians can do to help offset some of
those expenses we're joined now by
sylvanas charlevoix he's the senior
director of the agri-food analytics lab
at dalhousie university so sylvana thank
you for joining us let's start at the
grocery store food prices as we've heard
are up about nine percent over last year
why is that happening what's driving
these sky-high food prices well they are
macro factors canada is not alone this
is a global phenomena
so
you have to think about covet and the
pandemic and supply chain disruptions a
lot of companies have been trying to get
ahead of of some of the some of that
volatility and based on numbers that we
saw this morning it seems as though they
are uh
more in control of the supply chain than
they used to just a few months ago so
things seem to be more under control the
other issue of course is ukraine
commodity prices have gone up but those
increases have actually worked their way
through the supply chain now and so
we're seeing less volatility again as a
result of higher input costs would you
have any tips for grocery shoppers are
there any particular foods that people
should look for or avoid if they're
looking to cut costs
there are three sections where things
are still a little bit rocky one is
produce but produce is always
quite volatile for a variety of reasons
of course
harvests access bakery is a big one it's
been a non-story for five six years
prices are back up again ten percent
quite a lot so be careful the last one
is the most problematic one that's dairy
dairy prices have gone up way up since
january and we're expecting another bump
in the fall as kids go back to school
wow so another bump on the back to
school shopping bill
what kind of impact are these prices
then having on food security and
insecurity overall in canada the two
words we're hearing more and more often
these days is trading down a lot of
consumers are trading down
uh they're changing brands instead of
actually buying a brand they know they
may actually opt for a private label
label brand for our label product
they're they tend to be cheaper the
other thing we're seeing is that
consumers are changing address they're
going
and and then going out and visit uh
discount grocers and the differences are
quite significant 30 to 50 percent in
some cases and people are noticing
especially with a food inflation rate at
at 10
so
you have to do whatever you can in order
to save money you alluded to this
earlier but and i know this is largely a
guessing game sylvan but how long is
this expected to last we actually do
believe that the food inflation rate has
peaked in canada about a month ago which
is a good which is good news so we are
starting to see
the light at the end of the food
inflation tunnel so things are going to
probably end this year on a much calmer
note good news for all of us
prices will continue to rise in some
parts of the grocery store but generally
speaking you're really looking at a
situation that is more under control
okay well a little bit of good news so
we'll leave it there sylvan charlebois
the senior director of the agri-food
analytics lab at dalhousie university
thanks so much
heads up next the deadly risks to
earthlings from falling space junk
it's a simple rule of physics what goes
up must come down and despite the
vastness of space the laws of gravity
still apply to the objects we launch
into orbit a new canadian study is now
revealing the risks posed by humanity's
space junk when it comes crashing back
down to earth mike armstrong reports
they may be warnings we are missing
chinese long march rockets for example
once they reach space leave behind
massive rocket boosters they eventually
come down
back in 2020 parts of one crashed in two
villages in the ivory coast no one was
injured luckily but about 10 minutes
earlier parts had passed over densely
populated new york city well that's a
warning about what could happen michael
byers is the lead author of a new study
that looks at the risk abandoned rocket
stages mean to people on the ground
flashing the team analyzed the last 30
years of launches and came up with odds
that someone will eventually be killed
they say there's about a 10 percent
chance it will happen in the next 10
years
which is actually really small except
for the fact that it's growing because
more and more rockets are being launched
the number of countries and now
companies sending rockets into space is
skyrocketing that's more and more debris
even spacex's falcon 9 that brings back
its reusable main booster still leaves a
second stage in space for eventual
reentry
they tend to put on quite a show as they
break up this is debris from spacex
flying over seattle last year
and this is over lincoln oregon the
company tweeted out this week that just
since the beginning of 2022 it sent up
31 falcon 9 rockets where is it gonna
land the earth is big but we're not that
big and space debris is an issue and we
are not addressing it as much as we need
to
now one thing the study found is that
the danger is actually higher in
countries that don't send up rockets
because launches tend to be carrying
satellites into orbit near the equator
the odds are about four times higher
they'll land near the equator the major
space launching states uh they're
exporting risk to the developing world
the most frustrating part buyer says is
that today's technology makes all this
risk completely preventable he's calling
on governments to act mike armstrong
global news
and that is global national for this
wednesday night i'm jeff semple
tonight's your canada is the fairmont
empress hotel in victoria bc the
national historic site opened its doors
back in 1908. thanks for watching hope
to see you back here again tomorrow have
a great night
[Music]
you